Hello, I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We're the Slow Mo Guys.
Not in the back garden today.
Yeah, we're here with Blue Man Group.
Alright, lads.
I always associate Blue Man Group
with, you know, amazing
visuals, creativity
and generally just making a huge mess.
But today we're bowling.
Flip.
So when you have a 16 pound
bowling ball suspended
from the ceiling, it's very
important to have, well,
something to catch it with.
Well, luckily Slow Mo Guys and Blue Man
have got quite a lot in common,
'cause our first target is
gonna be multicolored jelly.
This could take a while to
whisk up in this giant buck--
Nevermind.
Whoa!
Get in there, there we go.
Dan, do the honors.
Absolutely. Ah.
Look at that, that's absolutely spot on.
Good job guys.
We should smash this before it melts.
Yes, we should.
Hey, this bit's mine.
Aww.
Got a good feeling about this one.
Yeah, You ready?
Count it off.
Okay. 3, 2, 1, drop.
No.
It just bounced like a trampoline.
No way.
If we sort of combined a bowling
ball with a cheese grater
somehow, it would separate
it into lovely segments.
Ahh, that would be even more
practical for these guys.
That'll be our next collaboration.
Yeah, next feeding time.
Yeah.
Usually, I have to do this on my own
y'know I usually have to
deal with crappy jobs.
Gavin says he's sorting the cameras out
but he's probably just
sitting there playing games.
Everything just gets trashed
I spend hours doing this,
it's soon just annoying.
Y'know, you're a really good listener.
It's just kinda strange
'cuz you don't really have ears.
This is definitely the most important part
of the Slow Mo Guys, erm
just the prep and setup and stuff
not the cameras or any of the editing
and that's why uh- why she left me
but, um- look at me now.
I'm doing this important work
fill out these sweet balls
but this is what Biance
does on her weekends
with uh- Jay Z.
Another power couple, yeah.
I've always wondered, uh- y'know
are you blue all over?
Or is it just like, uh,
just-just wondered, y'know.
Just... Curious.
What-what... Guess I blew it.
Nice stack, there, bet that took a while.
It-it did, yeah.
Oh, it did? Alright.
You ready to smash it now?
Ready.
K, cool. Alright.
3, 2, 1, Drop!
Ooh, bloody nora!
Tell you what, I'm not cleaning that up.
Well, I mean-
I am not cleaning that up.
Whaddya know, that is useful.
That is incredibly useful.
It's like a chest arse.
It is.
A charse.
Yeah, or chanus.
We should definitely buy him a cork
for his next birthday.
That is out of hand.
it's dribbly.
Here you go.
What do you want from me?
Put it on.
I clearly can't do it, look
how steady my hands are.
Brilliant, I'm done with
this responsibility.
They were counting on you, Daniel.
You can- you can do this just uh-
This is a lot of responsibility
this is precarious, okay- yeah.
I don't want to waste his chest juice.
It's straight from the heart.
Nobody move.
Slowly back away.
You ready?
I am looking forward to it- I'm ready.
You good?
Ready as heck.
Good, alright- 3, 2, 1, drop.
That made a mess. That
is a hell of a mess.
Gotta say, I love the 3D effect
that we've ended up here
for this masterpiece.
Yeah, I mean uh- we
sat out to make a mess.
I think that's a great success to us.
Probably deadly, too
so like, if you touch-
Good work.
Love it.
We get to keep this?
Thanks, guys.
That's excellent.
Aw, brilliant, guys.
Thank you so much.
Y'know, I think I'm gonna
put this in my bathroom.
Look at that.
Might just buy a mat for underneath it.
Whaddya think?
Well that was a lovely
amount of destruction
but it would be almost criminal
if we made a bowling video without
getting a strike somehow.
I'm not good at bowling though
so I can't really do that.
You are rubbish, I've seen you bowl.
I suggest that we build one of those
like, learner ramp cheat things.
I think that the blue men
took it to the extreme
and they made this monstrosity
so, uh, looks like
something from one of those
bridge constructing games,
yeah- it looks like Meccano
but for grownups.
So we're not just here to
make a video with the blue men
we also want to find out
what they're made of.
Yeah, do a little bit of research.
For instance, did you know there was
only ever 3 blue men at any one time?
Yeah, and when a blue man dies
they don't decompose, the
head just rolls clean off
and then a new blue man
is born from an egg.
Yeah, I found these 3 heads, y'know
covered from the other corner.
I think these ones are from
the '90s in the Vegas Show, actually.
Yeah, so let's ball a boy
into the sight of the end
and see what these ones are made of.
Alright, placing bets on
what's inside this one
whaddya think?
It could be anything, I don't know.
I reckon grape juice.
Grape juice?
Yeah, okay- are you ready, then?
Ready.
Alright, 3, 2, 1, drop.
What is that?
It's a cereal.
Lucky charms?
I feel bad for the blue men
having to witness that one.
I know, bits of skull
fragment went everywhere.
Should we make them do it again?
Alright, 3, 2, 1...
That's gruesome! God!
Oh, that looks like...
That looks delicious!
All right, final head.
This one's more of like a recreation
of when I get hit in the head with a ball.
Yeah, side profile, isn't it?
You didn't have a bowling
ball, though, so it's alright.
Well let's see what would've happened
if you were hit by a bowling ball.
Oh, God, alright.
You ready?
Yep, here we go. 3, 2, 1, go.
Eugh..
Oh, man.
Yeah, gladly I didn't use
a bowling ball for that.
It looks like Hunter worms.
Hunter worms?
Yeah, from- yeah.
Oh, like go low.
Yeah.
It's like, it's a little bit JFK isn't it?
If anything, I would say it
does go a bit sort of back.
Back, and to the left.
And to the left, yeah.
And to the left, yeah yeah.
Definitely.
Hold on to your chanus.
How about I just cover my
junk bellow just to be safe.
You ready?
Yeah, let's go.
All right.
Three, two, one, go.
What?
My God.
Where did the other--
What happened there?
Wouldn't that be good in real bowling
if you could do that?
Just--
Just push a button
and I missed
So by the time your ball gets there,
there's only one pin up.
Right in the middle.
That is clean.
I feel like for a split second, this pin,
well this lava lamp, was
feeling pretty lucky,
and then it got obliterated
more than any of the others.
Oh man.
There's just nothing left of it.
I'm pretty proud of that.
I think the Blue Men did a--
A damn good job of that.
That's how you treat your spare.
Well I thought that
was an excellent video.
I even got a nice piece
of art to take home.
I even got a nice piece of art.
I didn't.
Although, I didn't get messy or hurt once.
About that.
I've had a word with the Blue Men,
and you might want to strike a pose.
That's why they--
All right.
Huge thanks to Blue Men
Group for having us here
making this wonderful video.
Feel free to follow us on Twitter
and make sure you subscribe
to The Slow Mo Guys.
Yep.
Can you sign my lab coat.
Thanks, that's excellent.